Você sabia que existe um nutriente
essencial que a maioria das pessoas
nunca ouviu falar e que pode estar
diretamente ligado ao acúmulo de gordura
no seu fígado? Um estudo randomizado
controlado publicado no Therapeutic
Advances in Chronic Disease em 2025
mostrou que a suplementação de fosfatid
colina por 12 semanas reduziu
significativamente a esteatose hepática.
Estou falando de queda nas enzimas
hepáticas, redução no escoro de fibrose,
diminuição do estresse oxidativo, tudo
isso com nutriente que você
provavelmente nunca sequer dosou. O nome
dele é colina e hoje eu vou te explicar
porque esse nutriente pode ser a peça
que falta no seu tratamento.
Deixe contar o que eu vejo direto na
clínica. Chega o paciente com esteatose
hepática, cortou fritura, diminuiu o
carboidrato, começou a caminhar, tudo
certo, mas sabe que quase ninguém
investiga se o fígado consegue exportar
a gordura que ele produz. Porque não
basta só deixar de acumular, o fígado
precisa colocar essa gordura para fora.
E é exatamente aí que a colina entra. A
colina é considerada nutriente essencial
porque o corpo produz quantidade
insuficiente. Ela participa da síntese
de acetilcolina, contribui pra metilação
do DNA. E aqui está o ponto crucial, é
matériapra para fosfatidilcolina.
E a fosfatidilcolina
é componente obrigatório do envelope das
partículas de VLDL. Deixa eu explicar de
forma simples. O fígado produz
triglicerídeos naturalmente, mas esses
triglicerídeos precisam ser empacotados
uma cápsula de transporte chamada VLDL
para sair do fígado. Pensa no VLDL como
uma mala de viagem. Você coloca a
gordura dentro, despachxa pro corpo
utilizar como energia. O problema é que
essa mala precisa de um revestimento
específico que é feito de fosfatidil
colina. sem colina suficiente, o velho
del fica comprometido e a gordura não
sai do fígado, ela acumula e é assim que
começa a esteatose. Um estudo de
intervenção com 57 adultos saudáveis
alimentados com dietas deficientes em
colina mostrou resultados
impressionantes. 77%
dos homens e 80% das mulheres na
pós-menopausa desenvolveram fígado
gorduroso ou dano hepático. Todos esses
sinais foram revertidos quando a colina
foi reintroduzida. Tire a colina, o
fígado engordurou. Devolva a colina, o
fígado melhorou. E tem um detalhe
importante, as mulheres na pré-menopausa
tiveram menos problemas porque o
estrogênio estimula a síntese endógena,
ou seja, interna de fosfatid colina.
Após a menopausa, quando o estrogênio
cai, a necessidade de colina aumenta.
Muitas mulheres que desenvolvem
esteatose na perimenopausa ou climatério
podem estar simplesmente deficientes em
colina. Agora vamos aos estudos de 2025.
Pesquisadores da Enchan University
conduziram o ensaio clínico NCT 05200156
com pacientes com fígado gorduroso. O
grupo de intervenção recebeu 2400 mg de
fosfatid colina por dia por 12 semanas.
Os resultados foram significativos. O
parâmetro de atenuação controlada caiu
de 332 para 304.
O score de fibrose melhorou de 6,8 para
5,3.
As enzimas hepáticas ALT, que também
conhecido como TGP, e a ST, que é o TGO,
caíram, os marcadores de estresse
oxidativo despencaram e a leptina, o
hormônio inflamatório associado à
progressão da steatose, também diminuiu.
Mas por que que o estresse oxidativo
importa? Porque a deficiência de colina
compromete a função mitocondrial.
Estudos em hepatóstitos, células do
fígado, mostraram que a falta de colina
altera a membrana mitocondrial, causa
vazamento, reduz o potencial de membrana
e gera radicais livres em excesso. Esses
radicais livres são um dos principais
fatores que transformam uma esteatose
simples em esteatoepatite,
aversão inflamatória e perigosa. Então,
onde encontrar colina? As melhores
fontes são gema de ovo, uma gema grande
tem cerca de 140 mg, fígado bovino,
peixes e frango. O problema é que muita
gente evitou gema de ovo por décadas pel
aquela história de colesterol. Tem tinha
medo aí do aumento do colesterol. Então
essas pessoas também não comem fígado e
acaba consumindo muito menos colindo do
que precisa. A ingestão adequada
recomendada é de 550 mg por dia para
homens e 425 mg para mulheres. Dados do
estudo Nhanis publicados em 2023
mostraram que a maioria dos adultos não
atinge essa meta. Então o que que você
pode fazer? Primeiro, aumente fontes
naturais de colina, gema de ovo sem
medo, fígado, peixes gordurosos.
Segundo, se você tem diagnóstico de
esteatose, gordura no fígado, converse
com seu médico sobre suplementação de
fosfatidil colina. As doses nos estudos
variam de 10000 a 2400 mg por dia.
Terceiro, investigue com fatores:
vitamina B12, folato, betaína. Todos
participam do mesmo ciclo metabólico. E
lembre-se, a colina é uma peça do
quebra-cabeça. Dieta, exercício,
controle da resistência urínica
continuam fundamentais. A verdade é que
a abordagem convencional do fígado
gorduroso ignora nutrientes específicos.
O paciente recebe orientação genérica,
ppeso, faça exercício, mas ninguém
investiga se ele tem colina suficiente
para o fígado exportar a gordura. Seu
fígado não precisa só que você pare de
colocar gordura dentro dele, ele precisa
conseguir colocar gordura para fora. E
para isso precisa de fosfatid colina. A
bioquímica é clara, os estudos
confirmam. Saia do vídeo agora se você
gosta de ficar um superficial. Eu vou te
contar uma verdade conveniente. O
YouTube e o conselho me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens e
omitir protocolos controversos. Sobre
fígado gorduroso e colina, por exemplo,
eu não posso falar abertamente sobre as
doses mais altas de fósfaticina que eu
uso em casos de teatose avançada, ou
sobre combinações específicas com
crimarina e ácido alfalipôico que
potencializam os resultados. Na
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Eu compartilho os exatos protocolos que
eu utilizo na minha clínica, incluindo o
protocolo completo de reversão de
esteatose hepática com dosagens precisas
e cofatores que fazem diferença real.
Casos de reversão que pareciam
impossíveis, combinações ao flavor que
funcionam, fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames
hepáticos. É basicamente ter acesso ao
meu cérebro médico sem intermediários.
Nós temos lives semanais respondendo
perguntas, PDF com 47 protocolos
exclusivos, grupo no WhatsApp. Se você
quer a visão funcional real, sem
simplificação para as massas, clique
agora em seja membro. E não é para
curiosa, é para quem quer resultados.
Agora, se você quer ainda mais fundo,
existe o nível dois. A cada duas
semanas, fazemos live de imersão total
com 2 horas de duração, desse artigos
científicos linha por linha, como os
estudos mais recentes sobre metabolismo
hepático que a maioria dos médicos ainda
não conhece, debatendo controvérsias que
ninguém ousa tocar. E tem mais, seu nome
será mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna parte
visível dessa comunidade elite. Não é só
sobre aprender, é sobre pertencer ao
ciclo interno de quem está mudando o
jogo. Poucos têm essa coragem. Será que
você tem? E já que estamos falando de
fígado e metabolismo, você precisa
entender como a resistência sabota a
função hepática, porque esses dois
problemas andam juntos. Assista esse
vídeo aqui sobre os sinais silenciosos
de resistência que vai complementar
perfeitamente o que você aprendeu hoje.
Agradecimentos especiais aos nossos
queridos membros dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada do YouTube. Karim,
Lurdete, Carlos Roveri, Odonor Pinheiro,
Cíntia de Assis, Adriane BMS, Jorge
Cabral,
Marcelo Pimentel, Cláudia Leitão, Alex
Caldas, Ana Paula Vascular, José
Fortunato Murtinho, FS Machado RJ, Sou
Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril,
Estela Mares, Elô, Terapias Integrativas
e Saúde. Muito obrigado pelo seu apoio.